with the sixth pick
in the 2019 nfl draft
the new york giants select
daniel jones what would you tell those
fans who are
angry upset
that you picked daniel
what would i say to them
in in
in time you'll be very pleased
yeah that's dave gettleman the gm of the
giants making it known that they got
their man and chris you saw it coming
when words started to trickle out that
the giants were locked onto daniel jones
it was not a smoke screen it was a trial
balloon and apparently the trial balloon
flew well enough that the giants decided
to make him the sixth overall pick i
thought they'd wait until 17 but you
never know who else is out there who
loves the guy that isn't leaking to the
local media so that the fan base will be
ready for the arrival of daniel jones
their affection for the guy the giants
apparently realized we better not wait
they didn't wait and they get him and
uh it's it
look i'm not surprised because we knew
it was coming if we didn't know that
this is what they were going to do we
would have been shy would have been the
shock of the night by far if we weren't
already pre-positioned to understand
that this was going to happen yeah well
you know they they were scared of the
shock of the night so they wanted to
ease the giants fans into that over the
last 10 days i i can't lie the first
thing i thought of uh when they drafted
him you know uh and of course eli
manning's there it was very similar to
what happened to my dad and it wasn't
the draft but it was the supplemental
draft duke number 17 dave brown if you
remember that ultimately ended up being
the guy that replaced my dad here you
got duke number 17 ultimately gonna be
the guy that replaces eli manning yes
hey uh i don't love daniel jones i've
made that very clear there's there's a
listen i know he's a fine young man and
i know he's very smart and he's capable
of processing information and that
seemed to be the number one things teams
loved about him but with those type of
guys you really put more pressure on
your organization you know you really do
because you have to really
with these type of quarterbacks give
them an incredible supporting cast now
the giants have been able to do that a
lot of the times with you know eli
manning and things like that the problem
with this type of quarterback too though
that i always get into here is you know
when the team's not that good daniel
jones to me is not the type of talent
that is going to be able to get them
over the hump and steal some wins in
some situations where they had no
business winning a game that's what a
top 10 quarterback pick does he he can
carry the team and go oh we're not
playing as good okay don't worry guys
i'm going to have a day out here today
and i'm going to make some throws and
some plays and you know we're going to
look up and we're going to be winning
even though we were outplayed and didn't
play our best game that to me is the
definition of a franchise quarterback
that to me is my biggest question about
danielle jones i just don't think he has
a physical ability to do those things
now if he's got a lot of talent around
them hey they can win games certainly
but you know like i said that puts a lot
of pressure on the giants to always
supply that talent and have a good
scheme uh to where he can execute an
offense
one of the questions that came up on
thursday evening after the pick relates
to a connection that had been made by
people like gil brandt from daniel jones
back to eli manning's big brother payton
here's more from dave gettleman
how much of it has to do with daniel
jones by himself and how much of it is
the cut cliff factor the eli manning
paint we've heard him compared to peyton
manning trained by eli manning that kind
of you know
you know that's that's a nice piece
you know right i mean you know you know
obviously i mean
cut the you know
it's dave right
cliff yeah he's a hell of a coach now
right he didn't fall for turner truck
yesterday
so the kid's been well trained
that was almost a nick who moment he
acts like he doesn't know dave club's
first name he's the general manager in
the national football league how do you
know how do how do you not know david
cut club's first names like who who's
this manning who pat manning peyton i
don't no come on
that that's one of the ways they sold
this trying to bootstrap daniel jones
dna into the manning family chris so
again we're gonna have a hell of a poker
game one of these nights we'll go down
to the barn and we we already got a list
of about 10 or 12 guys bring them in and
we will clean up we will clean up make
sure they bring a lot of cash when we
play poker with them because we will
clean up that would be fun uh i do think
that was a huge reason why they took
daniel jones i really do now first of
all i want to pump the brakes on
anything being compared to peyton
manning i mean arguably the greatest
quarterback of all time certainly in
everybody's top five i mean peyton
manning again this wasn't just some
smart guy when peyton manning came out
of college his arm was legit i'm not
going to say we were sitting there going
oh this is aaron rodgers or patrick
mahomes but we said whoa that's a pretty
damn good arm and he was a phenomenal
athlete for his size and had a quick
release and could make power throws down
the field so i want to stop all the crap
about comparing this guy to peyton
manning peyton manning is on another
level i want to compare him to eli a
little bit sure i understand that and i
could see that a little bit more but i
do think this had everything to do and
this is why i was on this and said that
i thought they were going to take daniel
jones you can lock it in uh because of
some of the things you mentioned i mean
old world nfl here was in in in talks
ernia corsi was the gm who hired eli i
mean the drafted eli manning okay ernie
of corsi was hired by the giants to help
hire a gm he hired his buddy dave
gedelman okay then gilbrant got in the
conversation i mean hey gil brand and
ernie of course he have known each other
since the days of the dan marino john
elway trade they go way back like four
flats and a cadillac so yes uh i i i
just saw it coming to where this was the
selling point and i do think cutcliff
and the way daniel jones handles himself
in a meeting room and processes
processes information
was what they liked most about them and
i just think that's kind of a buyer
beware when you start the conversation
off with that type of stuff
and remember one of the other things
that dave gettleman is looking for is a
guy with the overall mental makeup to
thrive and survive in the new york media
market and i don't know how i don't know
how those hostile acc carolina crowds
well
i don't know that it's easy to glean
from that right i'd be more inclined to
to defer to a guy like dwayne haskins
who has gotten it done for ohio state
even though it was only for a full year
but that's one of the things gentleman
was looking for he's also looking for
a big guy to play defensive line and i
know you like this pick chris with pick
number 17 they go dexter lawrence the
clemson defensive tackle what do you
think of that i love that pick i mean
dexter lawrence uh i really thought he
was really you know top 15 worthy if
somebody took him at the end of the you
know number nine number 10 i wouldn't
have been mad i've never seen a 340
pound man move the way dexter lawrence
does it's special i've called him a
dancing bear
extremely athletic you and i talk about
it a lot being able to push the pocket
you know handle double teams in the run
game one on one he can beat you with
pure power or speed it's really a rare
rare athlete and i thought they knocked
it out of the park with the dexter
lawrence pick
and we were playing on the tv side the
clip of him getting the word and i love
the euphoria that was his mom that was
dancing in the foreground it was great
it reminded me of when the giants
drafted justin pugh a few years ago and
his buddies put him at the bottom of a
dog pile that's how excited they got so
great stuff and and uh happy guy to be
going to
new york to play for the giants pick
number 30 the giants got back into the
round they ended up with three picks
just like the raiders they trade up to
get de'andre baker the only corner taken
last night an area of need just because
their secondary has many areas of need
yeah definitely needed a corner i
thought maybe at 17 they might go a guy
like greedy williams i i'll say this
deandre baker is a good football player
i don't know if i think he's a great
corner that's going to have to be proven
to me first of all i don't think there's
too many great corners that run over 4-5
that would be the first thing that
scares me if you can't you know you know
four or five against guys like you know
aj green and julio jones who run four
three seven and all of a sudden you look
up and you go whoa they're a tenth and a
half faster than a guy like this i go
damn how's he gonna stay with him and he
doesn't play like he's faster than four
or four five two which he ran at the
combine i think he plays really maybe
even a hair slower that scares me there
now the guy is a great tackler he's
physical he's pretty smart so there
might be some position versatility with
him and maybe that's what they liked
about him ultimately but i don't
necessarily love the pick i would have
gone greedy williams all the way 6-2
runs 4-3 you know again i'll say this
for the ninth time you've heard me say
this there's a reason the greatest
cornerbacks of all time are the greatest
cornerbacks of all time you know dion
sanders daryl green darrell rivas champ
bailly you know rod woodson when he came
out charles woodson these are all guys
that are low four four
four three four two type of talent to
where they can run with anybody and that
allows them to be able to cover the
underneath stuff well because they don't
have to hit it into six gear to keep up
with people running down the field so it
gives them the ability to be able to
stop and start because they never have
to go a hundred percent when they're
running with other receivers because
they're that fast so those are my
concerns about a deandre baker um so
we'll see where that goes
yeah running 40 yards in a straight line
doesn't happen very often during a
football game but defensive backs
chasing receivers that straight line
speed is very important so point well
made by you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports